selamat kembali ke Quantum Computing in Practice saya hos kamu Olivia Lanes kali lalu kita telah menelusuri contoh pendekatan
Pengkomputeran Kuantum kepada masalah pengoptimuman yang dikenali sebagai Max Cut menggunakan perumusan QUBO kita pergi
agak mendalam tapi itu hanyalah satu contoh satu pendekatan hari ini kita akan membincangkan aplikasi jangka hampir
secara lebih luas dan membangunkan intuisi kita untuk jenis masalah yang berbeza yang kita jangkakan akan menemui penyelesaian Kuantum yang berguna
dan melihat beberapa contoh terkini kerja penting yang dilakukan dalam komuniti kita pada skala utiliti
sebelum ini kita telah membincangkan secara ringkas bahawa tidak semua masalah memerlukan kuasa pengkomputeran tambahan
khususnya Pengkomputeran Kuantum untuk diselesaikan dengan cekap ini adalah masalah yang sudah paling kamu kenali
aritmetik menatal media sosial mungkin bermain Tetris Doom atau permainan video lain kita secara umum menganggap
ini masalah mudah sebaliknya terdapat masalah yang sangat sukar seperti mencari faktor perdana bagi
integer yang sangat besar dan ini adalah asas penyulitan RSA dan apa yang algoritma Shore sebenarnya direka untuk menyelesaikan satu lagi
contoh ialah mencari penyelesaian dalam set data yang tidak disusun ini secara teoritikal boleh diselesaikan oleh algoritma kuantum yang dikenali
sebagai algoritma Grover walau bagaimanapun kebanyakan pakar bersetuju bahawa jenis-jenis algoritma ini akan memerlukan
pelaksanaan pembetulan ralat dan kita belum sampai ke sana lagi dari segi teknologi jadi apabila kita maju dalam
pelajaran ini dan dalam perjalanan pendidikan Kuantum kamu ingat kita sedang mencari titik manis di suatu tempat di tengah-tengah ini
ia adalah masalah yang sukar untuk dipecahkan tapi itulah juga yang menjadikannya sangat menyeronokkan satu perkara yang belum kita bincangkan
banyak ialah teori kerumitan pengkomputeran salah satu sebabnya ialah ia boleh agak menakutkan dan ya
kompleks teori kerumitan pengkomputeran adalah bidang sains komputer yang bertujuan mengklasifikasikan masalah pengkomputeran
mengikut betapa sukarnya terdapat banyak kelas kerumitan yang berbeza dalam Pengkomputeran klasikal tapi yang paling
asas adalah masalah P ini adalah masalah yang boleh diselesaikan dalam masa polinomial apabila skala masalah meningkat
bermakna ia mudah diselesaikan jenis masalah yang lebih sukar seterusnya adalah masalah NP yang
bermaksud polinomial tidak deterministik ini adalah masalah yang jawapannya boleh disahkan dalam masa polinomial tapi tidak
semestinya diselesaikan seterusnya adalah NP-complete dan kini kita masuk ke masalah yang benar-benar mencabar tanpa
penyelesaian polinomial yang diketahui di sinilah masalah terkenal seperti masalah pengembara jualan dan bahkan permainan
Sudoku berada kini apabila Pengkomputeran Kuantum mula ada sekurang-kurangnya dari segi teori orang menghabiskan usaha yang ketara untuk cuba
mengetahui kelas masalah apa yang komputer jenis baru ini akan dapat menyelesaikan dengan cekap kelas masalah baru
dicipta yang dipanggil masalah polinomial kuantum ralat terbatas atau BQP singkatannya definisi ketat mereka adalah
agak panjang tapi ia adalah kelas masalah keputusan yang boleh diselesaikan oleh komputer kuantum dalam masa polinomial dengan peluang
kecil ralat ada peluang ralat kerana pengukuran Kuantum secara intrinsik rawak tapi kebarangkalian
ralat boleh sekecil yang mungkin kini semua kelas ini berada dalam kelas yang lebih besar yang kita panggil PSPACE dan di sinilah
kita fikir BQP berada relatif kepada semua jenis masalah lain tapi sangat sukar untuk membuktikan ini secara definitif
secara matematik kamu akan perhatikan bahawa masalah kuantum BQP tidak semestinya bertindih dengan masalah NP-complete
walau bagaimanapun kamu mungkin masih pernah melihat beberapa pendekatan Pengkomputeran Kuantum yang bertujuan untuk menyelesaikan masalah NP-complete mengapa
ini terjadi satu salah faham biasa ialah tidak ada gunanya meneroka penyelesaian
kepada masalah seperti masalah pengembara jualan dan masalah NP-complete lain untuk komputer kuantum atau mana-mana masalah atau
bukti matematik untuk pecutan Kuantum belum ditemui walau bagaimanapun ini tidak semestinya perlu begitu
mencari bukti matematik bahawa algoritma Kuantum lebih pantas daripada algoritma klasikal yang setara adalah jarang Shore dan
Grover adalah dua daripada segelintir contoh sahaja di mana ini telah dilakukan setakat ini tapi itu tidak mengapa sebenarnya saintis
komputer masih belum dapat membuktikan bahawa kelas P dan NP adalah berbeza walaupun semua intuisi
memberitahu kita bahawa mereka mesti begitu juga membandingkan dua algoritma dan cara ia berskala sering melihat kes yang paling buruk
untuk setiap satunya adalah agak mungkin bahawa dalam amalan senario paling buruk bukan apa yang kita temui dalam kehidupan sebenar jadi kita
tidak berputus asa kita perkenalkan sebaliknya idea penyelesaian heuristik jika kamu seorang
eksperimentalis kamu sudah tahu dan menyukai jenis penyelesaian ini heuristik adalah mana-mana pendekatan untuk menyelesaikan
masalah yang pragmatik tapi tidak semestinya optimum dan itu bagus kerana penyelesaian tidak semestinya perlu
menjadi optimum untuk menjadi sangat berguna sebagai contoh fikirkan aplikasi kewangan kita belum menemui pecutan
eksponen untuk kebanyakan algoritma kewangan yang boleh digunakan oleh Kuantum lagi tapi itu tidak semestinya penting kita tidak memerlukan penyelesaian optimum
dalam kewangan sekurang-kurangnya kerana penyelesaian yang hanya 1% lebih cekap boleh setara dengan berbilion ringgit
keuntungan jadi bagaimana kita tahu kes penggunaan dan masalah apa yang sesuai untuk Pengkomputeran Kuantum sekarang dan dengan itu
saya maksudkan terdapat sebab yang ketara untuk mempercayai utiliti Kuantum atau bahkan Kelebihan boleh ditemui sama ada sekarang atau
dalam masa yang agak hampir mungkin lebih mudah untuk mula-mula menyenaraikan perkara yang pastinya tidak seharusnya dimiliki masalah ia
tidak boleh memerlukan bilangan qubit yang besar kita belum ada pemproses yang mempunyai ribuan hingga jutaan qubit tersedia itu adalah salah satu sebab utama
algoritma Shore dan seumpamanya masih jauh lagi litar juga tidak boleh sangat dalam ia sangat susah bagi saya
untuk memberitahu kamu dengan tepat kedalaman litar yang tidak akan berfungsi kerana ia bergantung pada begitu banyak faktor tapi secara amnya jika
eksperimen kamu memerlukan kedalaman yang belum kamu lihat dicapai dalam literatur lagi kamu mungkin akan menghadapi masa yang sukar dan
akhirnya sebarang jenis algoritma yang kita tahu akan memerlukan pembetulan ralat tidak boleh dilakukan lagi apa yang kita patut cari walau bagaimanapun adalah eksperimen yang menggunakan
kebanyakan qubit yang tersedia pada mana-mana QPU yang diberikan kita juga telah menekankan
kepentingan pengurangan dan penindasan ralat dan akhirnya harus ada sambungan yang jelas kepada aplikasi Masa Hadapan
yang akan penting untuk masyarakat dan yang kita boleh lihat akhirnya membawa kepada
Kelebihan Kuantum kini mari kita bercakap tentang beberapa contoh kes penggunaan yang termasuk dalam tiga kategori utama yang telah kita
kenal pasti sebagai paling mungkin melihat hasil yang menguntungkan dalam jangka masa hampir hingga pertengahan
kawasan pertama adalah simulasi alam semulajadi kita telah membincangkan ini sebelumnya terdapat
begitu banyak peluang bagi komputer kuantum untuk meningkatkan penyelidikan yang dilakukan pada peringkat molekul dan atom
WEBVTT
dan sebabnya ialah kaedah klasikal semasa dibatasi oleh penerangan matematik yang pada asasnya tidak cekap
bagi struktur atom menyimpan dan memanipulasi Keadaan Kuantum memerlukan jumlah sumber yang eksponen
pada komputer klasikal tapi boleh dilakukan dengan cekap pada komputer kuantum dan itulah yang menjadikan simulasi bahan
dan pemodelan kimia antara bidang aplikasi yang paling menjanjikan lebih khusus ini boleh membawa kepada
perkembangan dalam pemerangkapan karbon dioksida bateri alternatif atau penemuan ubat baru beberapa
algoritma yang sangat relevan dalam kawasan ini ialah penyelesai eigen kuantum variasi VQE yang digunakan untuk
menganggar sifat-sifat tertentu bahan seperti keseimbangan atau keadaan tenaga minimum satu lagi contoh ialah
simulasi dinamik masa TDS algoritma itu digunakan untuk menganggar fungsi respons atau sifat spektrum
bahan dan saya juga ingin menyebut pendatang baru pendiagonalan kuantum berasaskan sampel yang kita fikir akan kita
dengar lebih banyak tentangnya dalam masa terdekat kawasan aplikasi seterusnya adalah pengoptimuman kini pengoptimuman adalah agak
meluas dalam Pengkomputeran seperti yang boleh kamu bayangkan jadi kes penggunaan adalah cukup banyak dan pelbagai
walau bagaimanapun beberapa contoh yang sering kita dengar ialah pengoptimuman portfolio dalam kewangan reka bentuk industri dan juga
pengedaran dan rantaian bekalan algoritma yang paling biasa yang mungkin kamu dengar berkaitan dengan pengoptimuman ialah yang kita
sudah pelajari secara mendalam algoritma pengoptimuman hampiran kuantum atau
QAOA akhirnya satu kawasan yang terdapat banyak keghairahan dalam beberapa tahun kebelakangan ini ialah pembelajaran mesin kuantum kini saya
rasa wajar untuk katakan bahawa nampaknya QML tidak akan berlaku secepat simulasi dalam semua kemungkinan tapi walau bagaimanapun terdapat
beberapa algoritma yang menakjubkan yang sedang dikerjakan orang secara konsisten yang berkaitan dengan beberapa kes penggunaan yang sangat penting
beberapa kes penggunaan yang mungkin ini ialah pemprosesan bahasa tabii analisis trafik rangkaian dan bahkan pengesanan penipuan
dalam transaksi kewangan algoritma yang relevan dalam kawasan ini ialah mesin vektor sokongan kuantum
rangkaian neural kuantum dan rangkaian adversarial generatif kuantum kini untuk menjelaskan ketiga-tiga
kumpulan yang baru kita huraikan adalah kawasan aplikasi yang luas juga berbaloi untuk dinyatakan bahawa dalam komuniti terdapat juga
manfaat kepada kumpulan yang bekerjasama yang berfokus pada topik tertentu IBM telah memimpin satu inisiatif tidak lama dulu
yang dipanggil kumpulan kerja untuk cuba membantu kolaborator bertemu dan mencipta sinergi yang produktif dalam empat bidang tertentu
iaitu penjagaan kesihatan dan sains kehidupan bahan dan HPC fizik tenaga tinggi dan
pengoptimuman ini adalah kumpulan semasa kami dan entiti yang terlibat dalam usaha tersebut jika kamu ingin mendengar lebih lanjut tentang
apa yang kumpulan kerja sedang lakukan kami telah melampirkan empat kertas putih mereka dalam penerangan di bawah kini seperti yang saya katakan
saya fikir perkara terbaik untuk dilakukan pada ketika ini dalam kursus adalah meluangkan masa untuk meneroka jenis masalah apa yang sedang dikerjakan orang di barisan hadapan
teknologi ini dan membangunkan intuisi kita untuk mengetahui jenis algoritma apa yang akan berjalan dan cara
menerapkannya dan sebelum kita mulakan saya hanya ingin menjadikannya sangat jelas bahawa matlamat utama di sini bukan untuk memahami setiap
perincian eksperimen jenis analisis ini boleh sangat menakutkan bahkan bagi pakar jika kertas itu sedikit
di luar bidang kepakaran kamu matlamatnya hanyalah untuk membantu membangunkan intuisi untuk jenis masalah yang boleh digunakan komputer kuantum
dan cara menanganinya dan jika kamu berminat dengan perincian halus dan ini telah mencetuskan beberapa
idea kamu sendiri saya pasti menggalakkan kamu untuk pergi dan membaca sendiri kertas penuh tersebut kes penggunaan dan kertas
khusus yang kita akan lihat secara mendalam adalah ini pertama kita akan meneroka kertas yang membincangkan
simulasi dinamik hadron ini termasuk dalam kategori fizik tenaga tinggi seterusnya kita akan melihat masalah pengoptimuman
khususnya pengoptimuman kuantum counter-adiabatik medan bias dan akhirnya kita akan melihat satu lagi
masalah simulasi tapi kali ini fokus pada mRNA molekul penting untuk
pembangunan ubat dan terapeutik jika kamu biasa atau tidak dengan kertas-kertas ini tidak mengapa kita akan menelusuri
semua ketiga-tiganya adalah kertas penting yang menangani masalah berukuran besar dan menunjukkan bagaimana komputer kuantum
mula digunakan sebagai kaedah lain penyelidikan saintifik pertama adalah mensimulasikan dinamik
hadron dan kita akan menyelami kertas oleh kumpulan Martin Savage dari Universiti Washington yang dipanggil simulasi Kuantum
dinamik hadron dalam model Schwinger menggunakan 112
qubit jika kamu bukan ahli fizik tenaga tinggi kamu mungkin masih biasa dengan istilah hadron seperti dalam
Large Hadron Collider atau LHC iaitu pemecut zarah gergasi 27 kilometer lilitan yang menjadikannya
mungkin untuk akhirnya memerhatikan Boson Higgs kini hadron adalah zarah komposit subatom yang terdiri daripada zarah kecil lain
yang dipanggil quark beberapa contoh ialah neutron dan proton untuk sedikit konteks LHC dibina
untuk membolehkan kajian fizik asas dan apa yang berlaku kepada zarah-zarah apabila mereka bertembung pada tenaga yang sangat tinggi
dalam tiub bulat ini dengan melakukan ini saintis berharap untuk mengetahui lebih lanjut tentang bagaimana Alam Semesta awal mula wujud
dan seperti yang saya katakan sebelumnya ia juga digunakan untuk mencari Boson yang merupakan zarah sukar dikesan yang bertanggungjawab untuk jisim
zarah asas kini pada dasarnya interaksi zarah-zarah ini boleh
disimulasikan dari mula hingga habis dengan komputer kuantum yang cukup berkuasa kita belum sampai ke sana lagi tapi kemajuan
sedang dibuat kini model Schwinger adalah model mudah yang digunakan untuk mensimulasikan sebahagian daripada dinamik ini dan telah muncul sebagai salah satu
model pilihan yang paling popular perincian model ini tidak terlalu penting buat masa sekarang tapi bagi mereka yang
ingin tahu ia adalah model yang menggambarkan tingkah laku elektron dan positron yang berinteraksi melalui foton dalam 1 tambah 1 dimensi
bermakna terdapat satu dimensi ruang dan masa model ini mempunyai banyak persamaan dengan
kromodinamik kuantum yang menggambarkan cara quark dan hadron berinteraksi kini itu sangat sukar untuk disimulasikan jadi
model Schwinger sering digunakan sebagai model mainan untuk mengkaji beberapa fenomena yang sebenarnya biasa untuk
kedua-duanya kini cara kita akan meneruskan dengan contoh ini dan seluruh contoh lain yang saya pilih di sini adalah
dengan bertanya kepada diri kita sendiri satu siri soalan yang pertama ialah mengapa kita ada sebab untuk mempercayai bahawa mensimulasikan ini
pada komputer kuantum akan berjaya langsung dalam kes ini elektron dan positron dalam model Schwinger mempunyai kesan penapisan
yang menyebabkan korelasi antara fon yang jauh mereput secara eksponen dengan jarak pemisahan dan ini bermakna terdapat
WEBVTT
tidak terlalu banyak interaksi jarak jauh dari qubit di satu sisi cip ke satu lagi di sisi lain cip
yang kita tahu sangat terdedah kepada ralat jadi ini sangat baik untuk perkakasan yang kita ada hari ini seterusnya ialah
adakah topik ini bahkan menarik nah saya harap saya sudah agak meyakinkan kamu bahawa ya fizik tenaga tinggi adalah sangat
menarik orang sanggup membelanjakan berbilion ringgit untuk membina LHC dan ribuan saintis dan
juruteknik di seluruh dunia telah mendedikasikan hidup mereka untuk bidang ini begitulah pentingnya ia tapi
model Schwinger adalah mudah dan tidak direka untuk merangkumi tiga dimensi ruang walau bagaimanapun ia adalah
model penting kerana ia masih menyediakan hirisan yang boleh diuji pada masa ini dan penyederhanaan yang berguna bagi teori
penuh terakhir bagaimana kerja ini dilakukan atau pendekatan apa yang akan mereka gunakan jika mereka ingin meneruskan kerja dalam
eksperimen jenis simulasi VQE adalah antara pendekatan yang paling biasa dan langkah pertama hampir selalu sama
sediakan keadaan dasar dalam kes ini ia adalah Keadaan vakum dan dalam eksperimen ini mereka menggunakan versi baru VQE yang dipanggil SC
adapt VQE untuk menyediakan kedua-dua keadaan dasar dan paket gelombang hadron di atas vakum langkah seterusnya adalah kemudian
membiarkan hadron berevolusi atau merambat dalam masa akhirnya kita perlu mengenal pasti
boleh ukur yang ingin kita kesan kini jika langkah-langkah itu kedengaran agak biasa kepada kamu kecuali bahagian paket gelombang hadron
itu kerana langkah-langkah ini sangat serupa dengan apa yang kita pelajari dalam contoh QAOA dalam episod sebelumnya
diharap kamu mula melihat beberapa corak yang muncul di sini komponen yang diperlukan untuk VQE sangat serupa dengan QAOA
kita mulakan dalam Keadaan yang biasa di sini Keadaan vakum dan kemudian kita biarkan ia berevolusi dalam masa dengan siri Hamiltonian yang
dipotenkan dibahagikan kepada bahagian yang boleh diurus di mana n adalah bilangan bahagian satu-satunya perbezaan besar di sini
ialah kita mencipta paket gelombang hadron yang berpusat dalam litar kita sebelum kita mula membiarkannya berevolusi jadi bagaimana ini
dilakukan nah Keadaan vakum adalah keadaan dasar dan kita sudah agak pelajari cara memetakan ini kini menyediakan paket gelombang hadron
adalah sedikit berbeza pada vakum ini hadron boleh teruja dengan mencipta pasangan fermion anti-fermion pada
tapak yang bersebelahan dengan menyediakan superposisi hadron sedemikian di lokasi yang berbeza paket gelombang
sewenang-wenangnya boleh disediakan para pengarang memusatkan paket gelombang mereka di tengah litar untuk memerhati evolusi
tanpa melampaui sempadan tapi ingat nama permainan apabila bekerja dengan QPU yang bising adalah untuk mengekalkan
kedalaman litar yang boleh diurus untuk melakukan ini protokol SC adapt VQE menggunakan simetri dan
hierarki dalam skala panjang untuk menentukan litar Kuantum kedalaman rendah untuk penyediaan Keadaan ideanya ialah ini
akan mencipta ansatz dengan bilangan parameter yang lebih kecil bersamaan dengan kedalaman yang lebih cetek lebih banyak perincian sudah tentu
boleh ditemui dalam kertas daripada yang kita ada masa untuk pelajari di sini jadi pastikan kamu semaknya kini mari lihat hasilnya eksperimen ini dijalankan pada
peranti Heron IBM Quantum dan melaksanakan beberapa jenis pengurangan dan penindasan ralat yang berbeza
termasuk teknik yang lebih terkini yang dipanggil penormalan semula dekoherensi operator serta pemasangan dinamik pemisahan sifar hingar
ekstrapolasi dan twirling Pauli kini mari cuba tafsirkan data boleh ukur yang sebenarnya kita akan
ukur untuk memerhatikan bagaimana paket gelombang merambat adalah sesuatu yang dipanggil kondensat kiral yang agak
abstrak tapi ia pada dasarnya adalah fasa superbendalir hadron kini kita boleh melihat paket gelombang berpusat di sini pada
tapak yang telah ditetapkan untuk menjalankan eksperimen ini di mana warna berkaitan dengan kondensat kiral
sisi kiri menunjukkan hasil bebas ralat dari simulator manakala sisi kanan menunjukkan hasil dari komputer kuantum IBM
Torino dalam keadaan ideal ini sepatutnya menjadi imej cermin antara satu sama lain disebabkan simetri jadi kamu boleh melihat terdapat
beberapa ketidaksempurnaan kini paksi y menegak ini berkaitan dengan bahagian masa yang saya
ukur awal tadi jadi mengapa kita tidak membuat beberapa keratan mendatar melalui langkah masa pertama dan terakhir data untuk melihat
apa yang berlaku pada paket gelombang pada masa tau bersamaan 1 di sini dalam oren berkaitan dengan
keratan ini kamu boleh melihat bahawa kondensat kiral adalah sempit dan setempat ia juga berkaitan dengan sangat baik dengan
simulasi yang dilakukan untuk perbandingan pada tau 14 walau bagaimanapun ia jauh lebih tersebar dan kurang
setempat mungkin perbandingan dengan simulator tidak begitu sempurna kini tapi kamu masih jelas boleh melihat persetujuan yang sangat baik antara teori dan data
yang menggalakkan kesimpulannya ini adalah contoh yang sangat menarik bagi jenis kerja simulasi yang mungkin kamu tidak awalnya fikirkan untuk
menggunakan komputer kuantum walau bagaimanapun sebenarnya kamu boleh dan ia berjaya ia tidak sempurna tapi kamu tidak perlu menjadi pakar
fizik zarah untuk melihat bahawa komputer kuantum dengan tepat meramalkan perambatan ke luar paket gelombang
yang merupakan tepat apa yang kita jangka untuk dijumpai diharapkan kerja masa hadapan dalam kawasan ini akan diteruskan dan ahli fizik tenaga tinggi
akan terus mencari cara untuk menggabungkan Pengkomputeran Kuantum ke dalam aliran kerja mereka matlamatnya adalah untuk menyelesaikan masalah teoritikal dengan lebih tepat dan
masalah yang tidak boleh dilakukan secara klasikal dan menggunakan eksperimen untuk menerima atau menolak teori dengan harapan menemui fizik baru
membina pengesan yang lebih baik dan membawa kepada pemahaman yang lebih baik tentang alam semulajadi pada peringkat yang paling asas
contoh seterusnya kita fokus pada pengoptimuman dan akan menjadi penyelaman mendalam ke dalam kertas yang dipanggil pengoptimuman kuantum counter-adiabatik
berdigit medan bias yang dilakukan oleh ahli pasukan KIPU Quantum di
Universiti Basque Country di Sepanyol kita akan mulakan seperti yang kita lakukan sebelumnya
dengan siri definisi yang pertama ialah counter-adiabatik iaitu sejenis evolusi yang menindas kesan bukan-adiabatik
yang dialami oleh sistem tanpa mengira betapa cepatnya proses itu berlaku ingat teorem adiabatik dari
episod lalu kamu biasanya perlu membiarkan sistem berevolusi dengan sangat perlahan jika kamu mahu ia kekal dalam keadaan dasar
ini adalah masalah besar kerana semakin perlahan kita perlu membiarkan sesuatu berevolusi semakin banyak masa kita ada untuk ralat
berlaku pemacu counter-adiabatik yang sering disingkat sebagai CD bertujuan untuk memerangi ini dengan
menambah terma yang mengatasi pengujaan yang tidak dikehendaki ini idea utama di sini adalah mempercepatkan keseluruhan eksperimen dan
mengurangkan kedalaman litar Kuantum dengan menindas pengujaan yang boleh menyebabkan peralihan yang tidak diingini
kini mari kita bercakap tentang apa itu medan bias algoritma berulang lain seperti VQE mengambil parameter klasikal ke dalam
keadaan ini dan menggunakan pengoptimum klasikal untuk mencari ruang parameter berbilang dimensi bagi set tersebut
yang menghasilkan nilai jangkaan minimum untuk Hamiltonian tetap dalam kes ini mereka sebaliknya memvariasikan Hamiltonian setiap
WEBVTT
kali bergerak secara adiabatik dari kes yang diketahui ke kes yang diminati tapi kerana tiada parameter klasikal yang digunakan
dan tiada fungsi gelombang variasi bagaimana kamu mengemas kini keadaan kamu dari satu laluan pada Hamiltonian ke seterusnya nah
mereka menambah medan bias pada Hamiltonian apa sahaja keadaan tenaga terendah dari larian sebelumnya mereka menambah terma dalam
Hamiltonian untuk condongkan keadaan memihak kepada itu jadi mengapa eksperimen ini menarik
nah pertama sekali ini adalah pendekatan baru yang boleh diterapkan dengan lebih umum kepada masalah pengoptimuman lain
tapi dalam kes ini mereka menerapkannya pada masalah kaca putaran Ising seperti yang kita bincangkan sebelumnya banyak masalah pengoptimuman
kombinatorial boleh diformulasikan semula sebagai menyelesaikan untuk keadaan tenaga rendah Hamiltonian Ising model Ising
adalah siri putaran mikroskopik yang diedarkan pada susunan model itu boleh digunakan untuk menggambarkan kaca putaran di mana
kemagnetannya tidak teratur pada dasarnya momen magnet kecil diorientasikan secara rawak dalam susunan dan
mengapa kita fikir ini akan berjaya nah kita sudah agak pelajari cara kita memerangi dua isu biasa yang ditemui dalam
algoritma variasi apabila kita pelajari definisi kertas tapi untuk meringkaskan algoritma mereka
mencadangkan mempercepatkan evolusi untuk mengurangkan kedalaman litar sambil juga menindas peralihan bukan-adiabatik
selanjutnya ia tidak bergantung pada mana-mana rutin pengoptimuman klasikal yang boleh menjadi isu yang membawa kepada
dataran gundul dan terjebak di minimum tempatan akhirnya para pengarang juga memastikan untuk menjajarkan interaksi dalam masalah
Hamiltonian dengan kesambungan perkakasan dalam QPU sebenar yang sentiasa sangat penting akhirnya bagaimana ini berjalan jadi
seperti yang saya katakan tiada pengoptimum klasikal yang digunakan di sini seperti yang sering ada dalam algoritma Kuantum berulang
sebaliknya dengan memasukkan penyelesaian dari setiap iterasi ke dalam input untuk yang seterusnya medan bias berdigit
algoritma pengoptimuman kuantum secara bertahap memperhalusi keadaan dasar membawanya semakin dekat kepada
Keadaan akhir yang berevolusi dan digabungkan dengan protokol counter-adiabatik kita boleh melakukan ini bahkan dengan litar Kuantum kedalaman pendek
yang sepatutnya berjalan lancar pada Perkakasan yang bising jadi apabila eksperimen dilakukan para pengarang memilih untuk menjalankan
algoritma pada komputer kuantum IBM 127 qubit Brisbane di sini pengarang menunjukkan
pengoptimuman algoritma pengoptimuman bagi contoh kaca putaran yang dijana secara rawak jiran terdekat
lebih 100 qubit mereka membandingkan hasil simulasi ideal dari DCQ dan BF-DCQ
serta hasil eksperimen dan mereka juga menunjukkan hasil dari penyelesai klasikal yang dipanggil Gurobi sebagai rujukan kini
dengan hanya 10 iterasi BF-DCQ memberikan peningkatan yang drastik berbanding
DCQ walaupun hasil eksperimen sedikit berbeza daripada hasil ideal disebabkan hingar prestasi masih
lebih baik daripada DCQ ideal ini menunjukkan bahawa masih ada banyak kemajuan yang sangat baik dibuat dengan
menghadap pengoptimuman Kuantum dan keputusan yang baik dilaporkan pada lebih 100 qubit untuk pertama kalinya antara
yang pertama terakhir tapi tidak kurang pentingnya adalah kertas yang sangat menarik yang meneroka ramalan struktur mRNA dari rakan-rakan kita di
Moderna Pharmaceuticals dan ia dipanggil ramalan struktur sekunder mRNA menggunakan komputer kuantum skala utiliti
untuk memulakan jika kamu seperti saya masih belum mengambil kursus biologi dalam beberapa tahun kamu boleh menyegarkan diri tentang apa
mRNA adalah RNA messenger adalah sejenis RNA yang terlibat dalam sintesis protein ia
pada dasarnya membaca arahan yang diberikan oleh DNA struktur sekunder mRNA lebih kurang cara rantai dilipat dan
masalah ramalan struktur sekunder RNA adalah masalah mencari pelipatan paling stabil bagi jujukan
bes nukleotida yang membentuk DNA dan RNA iaitu C G U dan A imej
ini di sini menunjukkan beberapa struktur pelipatan biasa yang ditemui dalam mRNA setiap warna yang diketengahkan di sini menunjukkan
struktur sekunder yang berbeza tapi ciri-ciri tepat bagi apa yang menjadikan salah satu struktur ini lebih menguntungkan daripada
yang lain tidak difahami dengan baik semua yang boleh kita lakukan ialah mengetahui mana yang mempunyai tenaga bebas terendah berbanding dengan
keadaan tidak terlipat dan di situlah komputer kuantum masuk jadi mengapa struktur sekunder mRNA
penting nah ramalan yang tepat tentangnya sebenarnya sangat penting bukan hanya untuk memahami DNA dan gen kita tetapi juga
untuk mereka bentuk Terapeutik berasaskan RNA seperti vaksin covid-19 terdapat sebab untuk mempercayai bahawa pendekatan dalam
kertas ini akan berjaya kerana ini telah lama diketahui sebagai masalah pengoptimuman yang sangat sukar untuk komputer klasikal
disebabkan jumlah konfigurasi yang mungkin yang sangat banyak dan untuk sesetengah konfigurasi ia sebenarnya diketahui menjadi
masalah NP-complete walau bagaimanapun pada komputer kuantum kita boleh merumuskan ramalan struktur sekunder sebagai masalah
pengoptimuman binari sesuatu yang kita tahu cara menanganinya selanjutnya telah ada bukti dalam literatur sebelumnya
tentang ramalan RNA yang tepat pada peranti Kuantum berskala kecil dan simulator kuantum jadi soalan yang jelas ialah
adakah ini akan berjaya pada Perkakasan yang lebih besar eksperimen dilakukan dengan menggunakan sesuatu yang dipanggil penyelesai eigen kuantum variasi nilai risiko bersyarat
yang merupakan pengubahsuaian kepada algoritma VQE tradisional dan dijangka
mencapai penumpuan yang lebih baik plot ini menunjukkan taburan kebarangkalian pengukuran
rentetan bit sampel dengan tenaga yang berkaitan untuk
contoh 42 nukleotida 80 qubit di sini rentetan bit melambangkan pasangan
nukleotida ia menggambarkan bahawa rentetan bit tenaga terendah mempunyai nilai tenaga tolak 140 yang sepadan dengan rentetan bit
tenaga terendah yang dijumpai oleh penyelesai klasikal perbandingan jadi itu bagus dan ini adalah struktur terlipat optimum
bagi rantai nukleotida itu berdasarkan rentetan bit tenaga terendah yang dijumpai perkakasan
dan dengan itu kita telah sampai ke penghujung episod ini kini matlamat saya di sini bukanlah untuk melemaskan kamu dengan
perincian dari kertas penyelidikan yang berbeza seperti yang saya katakan saya hanya ingin memberi kamu konteks yang cukup untuk memahami apa yang
kerja barisan hadapan dalam bidang ini kelihatan seperti sekarang harapannya ialah ini akan menggerakkan beberapa roda dalam
kepala semua orang dan bahawa dengan melihat bagaimana orang lain mendekati masalah kamu akan dapat membuat hubungan dan mempunyai
keyakinan untuk mencuba eksperimen Kuantum baru yang mungkin kamu tidak pernah lakukan sebelumnya dan hei mungkin beberapa dari itu tidak
berhasil dan itu tidak apa itulah sebabnya ini adalah penyelidikan ke hadapan ingat bahawa jenis masalah yang kita
minat boleh dikumpulkan sama ada mengikut metodologi atau mengikut subjek dan kita telah menyusun yang kita percaya untuk menjadi
WEBVTT
yang paling menjanjikan dalam jangka masa pendek ingat Pengkomputeran Kuantum tidak bagus untuk segala-galanya dan ini sebenarnya hanyalah
bukti betapa baiknya kita dalam Pengkomputeran Klasikal hanya kerana kamu fikir kamu boleh menerapkan Pengkomputeran Kuantum
pada masalah tidak bermakna ia akan menghasilkan keputusan yang menarik sayangnya kamu perlu mempertimbangkan penskalaan kedalaman litar
adalah pedang bermata dua kita memerlukannya untuk menjadi sangat besar untuk melakukan kerja yang menarik yang komputer
klasikal tidak boleh tapi sekarang kerana hingar perkakasan kita tidak boleh menolaknya ke saiz yang sangat besar kerana kesetiaan akan
berkurang ia semua tentang mencari titik manis dan mengetahui bahawa ia adalah sasaran yang bergerak jadi luangkan masa
antara sekarang dan episod seterusnya untuk benar-benar memikirkan beberapa masalah yang pernah kamu temui dan bagaimana kamu mungkin ingin mendekatinya dengan apa yang telah kita pelajari
hingga ke tahap ini bersikap kreatif dan jangan hadkan diri kamu dan jika kamu mempunyai sebarang idea walaupun jika kamu fikir ia agak
gila beritahu saya dalam komen di bawah terima kasih kerana menonton dan saya akan jumpa kamu pada kali berikutnya